[Music]
sixteen inch MacBook Pro here it is I've
already made a video kind of talking
about it a little bit the unboxing but
now here we are over a week later and I
want to say that this is completely
replaced by iMac because I'm still using
it because I have projects that are
already saved on it but for the most
part I have almost entirely moved
everything over to the macbook but I was
talking before about my editing process
and my workflow everything pretty much
ran through a portable hard drive and
that is because I would be traveling a
lot so I would be editing on my iMac I
would just take that drive when I leave
and continue editing on my macbook
something else that happened this week
with this MacBook was I took part in an
editing challenge it was a Mac versus PC
editing challenge with Linus tech tips
I'm sure some of you guys are familiar
with him but one of his editors Taryn he
edits on a PC in Adobe Premiere and he
has all of these crazy keyboards and
macros and shortcuts he's an extremely
extremely talented at her so this was a
really fun challenge to do that was
really stressful for me because it was
one of the first times that I felt like
I was really being pressured we had four
hours to create this video so during
that time I was definitely pushing this
thing to its limits
equally as was only a one camera shoot
with some extra mural so it wasn't too
intensive but a lot of times videos like
this I'm using all 4k footage shot
directly from the a7 threes and I'm
editing in a multicam a timeline just
like this and it's fast I just can't
stress enough I mean yeah this thing now
has 64 gigs of RAM it better be freaking
fast and that to me I think is one of
the most shocking things because the
price of this computer I know a lot of
people who are saying it's really
expensive yes it is but when you think
about it this completely expect out
machine is like 60 $100 that is far less
than any of the other machines that I've
ever SPECT out for any MacBook ever I
normally would completely spec them out
just because I guess I'm crazy and this
is what I choose to spend all of my
money on this computer now is replacing
the 15-inch MacBook Pro it's basically
replacing it in price cheers I think
that that was a really great idea from
Apple's not to just add on a 16 inch you
basically have this whole thing
and this now is the new pro machine and
I think it could not be more fitting one
of the things that I haven't yet tested
out but I'm excited to do so in this
video is I'm gonna test out Apple arcade
using an Xbox controller so stay tuned
for that so obviously this is the 16
inch Retina display and the display it's
been really great so we really noticed a
difference in the screen size is what
I'm editing because I like to have all
of this stuff open even though it's
probably not the best way to edit but
I'd like to have access to everything
when I'm editing and I like to be able
to see everything I mean we'll have a
larger viewer here so I'm able to see
also more of my timeline so that's
already made a huge difference and then
let's talk about the hard drive fact
that this can go up to 8 terabytes is
incredible but to add on to the 8
terabytes that's two thousand two
hundred extra dollars which is quite a
lot but I feel like the fact that this
has the option of an eight terabyte
storage is pretty amazing because I
haven't seen very many 8 terabyte or
table storage options I mean I guess
maybe I haven't been looking in the
$2,000 range so if that's the reason why
the RAM also starts at 16 gigs which is
so incredible that's what my previous
MacBook was able to be maxed out to
extra $800 for the 64 gigs of ram worth
it
the speakers sound amazing
[Music]
I edit without headphones a lot of the
times and it's incredibly annoying to
everyone else around me but that's how I
edit it's not great this is also running
Catalina which gives us access to
sidecar and I never use sidecar until
today
and of course everyone thinks that me
being an apple fangirl I'm always super
hyped about everything
initially it wasn't only that excited
because I didn't think that it would be
something that I would ever really use
even though in theory it sounds like a
great idea but for whatever reason it
wasn't into it so I never tried it and
today I tried it and guess what I'm into
it to get sidecar to run you have to be
on the same Wi-Fi network and have both
devices beyond the same Apple ID gonna
go up here to airplay within seconds
like this is my mirrored desktop so when
I'm editing I can use the Apple pencil
this is my file browser I can use that
to select ranges put it into our project
and that whole thing it just goes right
here into our timeline you can also set
this up to be a viewer so I can use this
to edit this could be my viewer off to
the side like this
I'm new glad that I finally tried out
sidecar because it's pretty great let's
test out Photoshop here so right now I
have the displays being mirrored it's
also got some shortcut keys here on the
side so you have a nice undo there which
always use undo way too much especially
when I'm in Photoshop look at that
beautiful work of art I can use all the
menu items with my Apple pencil
[Music]
my work of art so they say you're gonna
get about an 11 hour battery life which
is about an hour more than the previous
15 inch and it's crazy because obviously
this does have a bigger battery it has
the largest possible capacity battery
that you can legally carry on to an
airplane have noticed that the battery
life has been significantly increased
now I will never ever at 11 hours of
battery life because I'm always doing
things that require a lot more processor
so if we're meeting at 11 hours battery
I think I'd probably just have to be
looking at my computer even editing that
first video that I did of the review of
this I was on a plane I was in uber I
was in cars I was working out of coffee
shops I was working in restaurants that
first day it for me it was a perfect
scenario to really test this out the
battery life was great it got me from
basically New York to Nashville
I thought maybe because the computer was
a little bit bigger that I would notice
a difference when I'm on a plane but I
had no issues at all the overall size of
it is a little bit bigger than the
previous 15-inch they did a really great
job of decreasing the bezel sizes on the
display so that they were still able to
keep this as small as possible and not
make it that much larger than the
previous computer it is 0.3 pounds
heavier I didn't really notice a weight
difference I mean obviously this is a
pretty beefy computer the 15-inch also
isn't exactly the lightest thing ever
when you have it in a backpack full of
other gear of course I would wish that
it was lighter but the amount of power
I'm 100% willing to sacrifice that point
three pounds and one of the things I
want to make sure I did in this video
will show you the size comparison of the
16 inch macbook pro to the 15 inch
MacBook Pro series can see the slight
difference between the 15 inch and the
16 inch there is the size difference I
think a lot of people thought that it
was gonna be the same footprint as the
15 inch this really isn't that much
bigger when you think about the 17 inch
MacBook Pro that was a monster of a
machine I had always wanted one of the
17-inch Mac books but they were just so
huge so there was no way that I would
ever be able to lug that thing around
but this is such a small difference that
if you are used to carrying
around carrying the 16 inch is not gonna
make much of a difference at all what
you're looking at both of these screens
side-by-side obviously you could tell
them as well as larger the bezels are a
little bit smaller there's still a big
black bar up here that houses your
FaceTime camera eyesight I so-called
eyesight even though I don't think
called that for like ten years
one of these days I'll be waiting for a
nice 4k built-in camera
but until then I really don't use it
that often so I guess it doesn't matter
that much
the cooling on this MacBook has been
amazing I know I mentioned that already
the new fans of the new cooling mechanic
it's made a really big difference what
are you even doing well you're doing
some updates that's sweet Apple TV looks
amazing on this thing and of course if
you do buy a Mac or an iPhone you do get
a year free subscription I definitely
recommend watching the morning show the
screen looks great the keyboard is also
something that I haven't talked about
yet it's a new keyboard it's a scissor
mechanic which kind of goes back to
their previous version of their
keyboards like the 15-inch 2015 then
they switch to the butterfly mechanic
which was the past few versions of the
MacBook that they had I still love the
butterfly keyboard I had no problems
with mine and I do feel like this
keyboard there's a little more travel in
the keys so you do have to press a
little bit more it also has a separate
Escape key so that is no longer digital
and attached to the touch bar
I think this MacBook has addressed a lot
of the concerns that many people had
keyboard screen real estate size storage
Ram basically I think anything that we
may have wanted the inner pearl MacBook
I think we got it
I just want to document this moment in
time on the internet this is the first
time that I am playing with an Xbox
controller on my brand-new MacBook in
Catalina and we're playing the hot lava
game I'm also recording this using
QuickTime this is so exciting so when I
first started this up it gave me a
little system preferences thing the game
kept covering it up so my xbox
controller wasn't working initially
decided go into the preferences into the
privacy settings and make sure I granted
access to my xbox controller so you guys
ran into those at all this is probably
the dialog that you would see
look at me doing parkour oh gosh how
many of you guys played Apple arcade if
so oh gosh but what games have you
played ok the floor is lava it is very
hot so jump plus it was a great concept
I could play this with a mouse and
keyboard but crouch or jump to like oval
pipe
well I clearly figured that already I
appreciate I have these little gems mats
in my gym jump at the correct time on
trampolines to go higher it's not your
gosh this is fun if you play it on the
iPad or the iPhone because you can use
the accelerometer okay so I'm getting
really good at this so I think that I
might be going pro I'm gonna be the next
eSports champion Oh the floor is lava I
will see you oh it's just as I got cocky
I died is that a friend over there I
hurt you get my friend are we friends
hi oh my gosh hello friend okay won't go
away we're gonna go now is the question
I guess I'll just jump down here I think
I broke my leg if you guys wonder why
sometimes Emma I might not post videos
here in the future it's probably because
I'm not playing the floor is lava can't
think of anything negative to say I was
really trying because I know you guys
always want to hear me say something
negative I'm sorry I don't have any
problems with this so far like I can't
even think of it another oh one thing I
have thought of something the iSight
camera that definitely could have been
something that was upgraded even though
I rarely ever use that anymore a really
fun fact some of my first youtube videos
that I ever shot I shot them using an
iSight camera and a really good
microphone you just gonna pull that out
I saw show you guys where we started or
at least where I started
this was a few laptops ago still has the
light-up MacBook I'm not actually sure
what year this one was you could find a
plug to power it up but it's interesting
because I was talking about the keyboard
so this is probably like it may be 2015
okay it's definitely not exactly the
same it does feel a little bit like in
between the butterfly keys and the
scissor what I really wanted to show you
is this beast this was I think the first
MacBook Pro a really beautiful machine
can you just take a look at how small
that trackpad is compared to this one
this also is the same size trackpad as
the previous 15 that is quite a type but
this computer right here this is what I
made some of my first youtube videos on
little eyesight so if anybody ever tells
you you can't do something that's not
true I basically built my entire career
off of this I know I'm sitting here
talking about a very expensive a
top-of-the-line computer but I will
never be able to stress this enough to
you guys that whatever you have is good
enough to get started on and when you
feel it's time to upgrade that's when
you do it I do love this keyboard it's
just so great how it's all silver blends
perfectly in with a macbook case you
guys would like to see a justine reacts
to what's on her old MacBook give me a
thumbs up and leave me a comment below
and let me know so I think when you
think about you where we came from where
we are now it's pretty impressive this
thing was such a beast I spent all of my
money when I had quit my job to buy this
computer and it was probably the worst
decision but also the best decision I
ever made could I pay my rent absolutely
not did this get my career started and I
owe so much to this little guy I'm
starting to get a little emotional now
so that's been my initial reaction to
the new MacBook Pro I just don't know
what else to say other than it's perfect
I'd love to hear what you guys think in
the comments below what have you seen
from other people's reviews and if you
have on yourself what do you think so
for everything I need
is
it it can do it I do plan on doing an
Ellen video within a month or so after
I've really been using it as my
day-to-day computer I do want to see how
it holds up after I have everything
installed I pretty much have most of the
things that I need but I I love it
[Music]